they look like any european family
around the world a sea of blue and
yellow from berlin to prague to seoul
the colors of the ukrainian flag now a
call to action don't stay at home choose
your voice go up ukrainian cities have
been found
worst violence in a year and it's only
day two of what israel says could be a
week-long bombardment of the gaza strip
how would you compare the reporting in
the media in gaza at least 44
palestinians including 15 children have
been killed in three days of an israeli
military bombardment well you just told
me that we intercepted almost all the
rockets and nobody got injured i think
there was three slight injuries in
israel
so why did you have to kill the 66
palestinians
so uh foreign shields human shields yeah
by the way israeli defense forces use
human shields all the time they will put
palestinian children in front of them
and enter a building so they don't get
shot they're disgusting okay and then
they pretend that and then they pack
everybody into gaza they got two million
uh people in an open air prison and they
go well if i drop a bomb in the middle
of your city it's not my fault it's your
fault for having civilians there and we
are here to show our solidarity to
ukrainian people with ukrainian people
and support them in their fight for
their independence
sovereignty of the country relatively
civilized they look like any european
family christians they're white you know
this is a relatively civilized uh
relatively european i have to choose
those words carefully too uh city where
you wouldn't expect that or hope that
it's going to happen when they say oh
civilized cities and in another clip
well-dressed people and this is not the
third world
they really mean despite my lovely head
scarf here it was given to me by some
people
um i'm i'm not muslim i'm not arab my
background is christian i'm very
mainstream american very patriotic
american i grew up in a military family
my father had served in world war ii
wake up there are over 300 million
americans that don't know what islam is
this is why we are opening the dean
center the first of its kind 35 000
square foot tawwa center and masjid to
show america the beautiful message of
islam inshallah with your help and
donations we can close on the property
launch nationwide programs a
state-of-the-art production studio for
online content and an on-site dawah
center to show what true islam is donate
right now may god almighty allah reward
all of you
[Music]
alhamdulillah
greetings of peace welcome to the dean
sean eddie hold subscribe if you haven't
already hit that notification bell my
next guest
allison weir is an american human rights
activist and president and founder of
if americans only knew the mission of
americans if americans only knew is to
inform and educate the american public
on issues of major significance that are
unreported underreported or misreported
in the american media
and without further ado let's bring out
our special guest allison weir how are
you doing allison i'm good thank you how
are you thank you for having me thanks
for coming back here on the dean's show
how have you been
busy
busy yes so tell us latest developments
we reading in the news more than is it
15 or more than 15 innocent young
children there's bombs flying again in
palestine there can you just bring our
audience up to speed on what's going
exactly what's going on what caused this
again to erupt
sure i'll be glad to um
yes the the numbers keep growing because
just today it looks like another 10 year
old girl in gaza a little girl who loved
dancing
like many ten-year-olds
just died from wounds that she sustained
during israel's recent bombardment of
gaza
she's at least the second ten-year-old
to just die from wounds
from israel's attack uh it is i think it
must be approximately 17 children now
that have died
um
in gaza
uh it's something like 47
people in all were killed by israelis
israeli airstrikes on gaza
in addition to that
as if that weren't enough israel then
there were demonstrations and various
events in the west bank so israel killed
about four or five more people in the
west bank
uh some of them also minors
and also a lot of reports are leaving
out that i i believe
israeli forces in their bombardment you
know supposedly to get you know one or
two
resistance fighters they just pummeled
the whole area
and uh something like a thousand homes
were damaged a thousand
yeah
so that's that's
that's under the pretext that what again
well they were going after one basically
um it started with killing one
senior commander in the palestinian
resistance forces in gaza
on that strike even on that strike what
u.s media tended to underplay or maybe
not even report is on that strike they
also killed a 16 year old
what's causing it is a little unclear
the israeli media
are speculating this is probably
as validity
that what's going on is that the prime
israel is getting ready for some very
close races electoral
races just the way
the us is
so there's lots of maneuvering to win
the voters over
and the current israeli prime minister
yer lapid
israeli media are suggesting launch this
to show how tough he is so that voters
would vote for him because sadly many
israelis are very happy
that at what israel is doing because you
know their propagandized too
so
the idea is that this he may have
launched this just to show how tough he
is to get votes
how would you how would you compare i
mean anytime the innocent human life
is taken it's sad no matter where it's
at so where you have in this situation
how would you compare
because
you guys are watching this you're seeing
what's happening
how would you compare the reporting in
the media
in ukraine
compared to
here what's happening with the
palestinians in this part of the world
of course it's just night and day
just night and day
so the the american population and and
a lot of people are starting to pick
this up but they don't always know
what's going on so much in israel
palestine
but of course you know the media sadly
most most of them the legacy corporate
media
basically
have an agenda quite often at the top
the
reporters lower down are trying to do a
good job usually working very hard not
especially well paid
but at the top
there's an agenda that often matches the
agenda of the democratic party
establishment and the u.s establishment
in general so right now the
establishment has clearly decided
a journalist named matt tayeby has
documented this very well
so russia is the enemy
um ukraine is the victim
the fact that nato expanded in ways that
were broke promises that had been made
are left out so we see
the suffering and devastation in ukraine
which is
is good i think we should always know
when people are dying and suffering
but the establishment doesn't think that
people should know about palestinians to
the same extent and to people in gaza
so you know on the one hand they see the
suffering it makes them
empathize with those people want to help
them in ukraine
they don't see really what's happening
in russia
and they don't see you know what much
longer than ukraine has been going on in
the palestinian occupied territories
especially in gaza but also often in the
west bank
if they did that's why we named our
organization 20 years ago if americans
do
because if americans knew that we're
giving israel
well over 10 million dollars per day of
our tax money
when many people are struggling to make
that money
and the way israel is using it so often
to oppress
palestinian families you know it's
always portrayed as oh it's just hamas
or it's against
the fighters or against quote terrorists
and people don't say no it's against an
entire population it's against families
it's against children against seniors
against people that have been suffering
for
what is it now 15 years of us of a
suffocating siege by israel
so if americans knew that and knew that
our fun our money is funding it i think
they would demand very different u.s
policies
do you think if americans really knew
what was going on
and
you had what was done in ukraine with
russia you had all these sanctions and
you had all the sympathy and support for
what's happening
in ukraine how how much because you
don't get the same sympathy a lot of
times there's a spin put on things and
people are kind of
ignorant to really what's happening but
if they really really knew
do you think it'd be a different story
i think it would be a very different
story consistent you know most
populations
the majority of around the world are
good people
that want to just live their lives and
not cause suffering to other people you
know it's pretty simple that's how most
people are you know you just see that
around you but they can be propagandized
that happens also with lots of
populations
so the american population
what i've seen i've been working on this
issue now for over 20 years
and what i've seen is among
the popul the
left half of the country the people that
are tend to be democrats and
progressives and liberals
have started to learn more about what
actually is going on in palestine
and the
the sympathy has changed to a large
degree not among the power brokers or
the campaign donors who are usually
hardcore israel partisans but among the
grassroots there really is much more
understanding and sympathy for
palestinians
however
among conservatives who are also good
people
you know who care about human beings but
in that population we haven't done as
good a job of reaching them and they're
getting a great deal of propaganda that
suggests oh you know palestinians are
terrorists they're attacking poor israel
they often think it's the opposite of
what's going on so that population
is often less informed it hasn't always
been that k that way
some of the people who first
started exposing the real facts about
israel-palestine were republicans paul
findley
chuck percy
pete mccloskey
patrick buchanan
so
that population also when they learn the
facts becomes sympathetic to
palestinians
but most
sadly
many many conservatives are very very
misled on this issue by the u.s media
how do you address that when it comes up
the response that someone says oh
they're terrorists they're this they're
that
for someone like yourself who's been
an american who's been
watching this for over 20 years so when
someone comes up and makes makes this
kind of statement how do you like to
address that i like to give them the
basic facts i like to emphasize i'm not
as despite my lovely head scarf here it
was given to me by some people
um i'm i'm not muslim i'm not arab my
background is christian i'm very
mainstream american very patriotic
american
i grew up in a military family my father
had served in world war ii
so i'd like to
give you know first of all when you tell
when you talk to an american and say
well you know the media are very biased
they always agree
um but they think that their own media
are not real you know are not biased
they agree the media are but they still
believe what they're getting
so you have to sort of explain no you
know they then they'll tell you what's
going on
you'll say well where did you learn that
and of course it's from the media
you know very few people have gone over
there
very few people have the time to
independently study all these important
issues more likely to have studied if
anything a local issue
so
it's in a one-to-one conversation it's
difficult because there's so much to
overcome
but you can do it bit by bit by bit if
you can have a long enough conversation
fortunately i have in the past years had
the chance to speak many places where i
can get up at a podium and i have an
hour to explain what's going on
and at the end of that hour i one time i
did this in
in northern california
and afterwards some of us were having
dinner at a nearby restaurant and this
older couple
senior citizens about my age
stopped by our table and said i want to
tell you we were at your your talk and
you completely turned us around on this
issue wow
so that's because they had had a chance
to hear
for an hour lecture
with evidence not with hyperbole not
with a lot of
not not
overly emotional of course i do get
emotional at times during it but
basically just laying out the real facts
and providing the evidence for that so
when you can do that
many people will be reached but in a
one-to-one conversation of course it's
harder to have the time to to do that
but i think
but not to be discouraged i have
met people that are working on
telling people and working about trying
to bring justice for palestinians
that are mainstream americans like me
you know ask well you know how did you
get involved what what woke you up to
this
and quite often they'll say well there
was a co-worker that was palestinian
or when i was a student one of the other
students was palestinian
so many of them were wakened up
by just you know getting to know
somebody who was a palestinian-american
or a muslim american or an arab american
that would tell them what was going on
and that often does reach people
because most people
don't have strong views on it
so you'll hear from the people that have
you know think they know what's going on
and they're very you know forceful
but most people don't have a strong view
there they find it a confusing issue and
they don't know much about it
so even with the grass the gas
prices going up
and with all the inflation that 10
million dollars a day
which probably most americans don't know
that their hard earned tax money is
going towards this
10 million a day even with the inflation
and gas flight prices has it gone down
at all or it's still
10 million a day it's so it rarely goes
down
but
victory of the money to israel is that
basically
basically it it
sort of steadily creeps upward
and it's it's largely because
this the media rarely cover it
most people have no idea how much money
goes there
yeah you know and that shows right there
the kind of cover-up we're getting and
the kind of very filtered information
because
you know major facts people tend to know
so wouldn't we know the number one
recipient of our tax money for decades
has been
has been israel now and then there are
blips right now ukraine is getting a
huge amount
and people know that
but before that for many years israel
was the top recipient and almost nobody
knew that
uh when i first started on this issue i
live in the san francisco area
so we looked into the san francisco
coverage of
of palestine israel in general
and among the things we looked at is how
often did they tell people how much
money goes to israel out of hundreds of
stories on the topic
we discovered it was only three times
that they even mentioned it
you know down usually down low
and never did they really give the full
amount
so you know it's
some media now are starting to give that
after 20 years i think i think our
organization and others have started to
have an impact i think the coverage is
not as bad as it used to be
at all
but it's still very very filtered
hasn't the international community and
many of the courts
deemed
this an illegal occupation the illegal
settlements
isn't this something that is
just uh unanimous
yes you talk about that
yes the um
[Music]
that's that's the international
consensus international law is that
these israeli settlements and really in
in some ways you know even the language
of course is very skewed because these
are illegal israel jewish colonies on
somebody else's land
and i don't use that word because i'm
anti-jewish many people many of my
allies working on this issue are jewish
americans and some are israelis
but so you for you have this is really
important you have israelis and jews who
are working like i have a good friend
miko pillett he's uh have you heard of
mikko pilot yes
yeah he's also an israeli uh jewish man
whose father was the signer of the
declaration of independence father was a
general in the israeli army and he's
also just one great example of someone
who is just
fighting for the truth
that's right like yourself
so go ahead i'm sorry
so um
but but these is these illegal colonies
you can't just call them israeli
colonies because
a portion you know about 20 percent of
the israeli population are palestinians
the ones that were not completely pushed
out of in
1948 and then again in 1967 there's a
portion that have remained there they
often were pushed off their own land
you know out of their own homes but
they're still supposedly israeli
citizens
they're of course not allowed to live in
those israeli colonies so they're really
jewish only colonies often
you know a jewish american from brooklyn
might have moved there and is living on
land that very recently was
was stolen from palestinians who had
owned it for you know generations
so that's illegal that's not allowed in
under the geneva conventions another
some you know other international law
that's not allowed you're not allowed to
steal people's land you're not allowed
to move your population onto somebody
else's land
you're not allowed to you know
consciously change the demography it's
all this is all well articulated in
international law
and this is recognized internationally
but in the us that's almost never
mentioned
so that's why it's very important uh if
americans only knew because they
understand that here if one country
comes over it starts to occupy and take
land like in ukraine
over here they've been doing it for how
long coming and stealing the land
but you can't you got to be consistent
you can't have double standards correct
that's right and again
these are american principles you know
some people try to say oh you know
israel is so much like america that's
why we support it no it isn't
you know we have a constitution they
don't
and we have a lot of
principles that we believe in we believe
in
in um not establishing as eight religion
that was right in the constitution
israel is based on a state religion
um
i think most americans are very strongly
committed you know we use the word fair
we want people to be fair you know i
have grandsons playing little league and
they're very upset if something's not
fair
so we want fairness i think we believe
in justice
we of course were founded by
a violent revolution the revolutionary
war you know 1776 period of time
so we would be very sympathetic to
people we we fought against oppression
and
um
you know taxation without representation
all of that that's embedded in in our
in our national history so we would be
very very we would identify with
palestinians who are fighting for their
own independence and justice
so these are very american principles
the only thing that's getting in the way
is that people are being misinformed on
one of the most important issues in the
world you know not only because of the
suffering it causes to human beings on
the other side of the world but it
destabilizes destabilized the entire
region
for decades
it's caused wars in which americans have
not fought and died
sadly for israel
it's caused u.s policies that cause
hostility to the united states so this
is not only bad for the people in the
region this is very very damaging to
americans also
and if people knew that they would be
upset too
how do you like to address the the issue
you know the name calling that happens
and then the stigma that gets attached
to someone uh the term anti-semitic i've
had also rabbis come on the program who
make it
lucidly clear that judaism this is
against the teachings of orthodox
judaism
they will say this is
the zionism this is the problem so these
are rabbis so i've had rabbi weiss uh
rabbi shapiro and others who come on who
are strong voice also but then this term
gets thrown out you know anti-semitic
they'll throw it on you hoping it'll
stick
and also that oh these are just muslims
they hate jews i don't know if you've
heard this also
how do you respond to this
well that is a tactic you know that's a
tactic being called anti-semitic is very
offensive and very damaging
very damaging and very offensive
so they do that all the time
and um after a while you just have to
you know that's what's going to happen
when you speak about this
and it should not silence people
mudslinging should not silence people so
in my own case of course that was done
immediately even before like now part of
what i try to do is tell people
about the the you know influence of a
very powerful special interest the
pro-israel lobby
but even before i did that even when i
just i had traveled as i mentioned i
think on your earlier program
i had traveled over to palestine to the
occupied territories in early 2001
before 9 11
and saw
firsthand what was going on took
pictures of what was going on
and so when i came back and started
giving talks
showing people my pictures telling what
i personally had seen
not even mentioning the israel lobby i
wasn't very aware of that yet
i'm just for doing that i was called
anti-semitic because there's an effort
to conflate
israeli actions with all jews which is
unfair so it's the
irony is that if anybody's anti-semitic
it's often the pro-israel establishment
because they're trying to say oh these
are jewish actions no all jewish
americans are connected to this
so to me that's anti-semitic and that's
not what what what i say
or or other activists working on this
issue say
what's even worse is that not only have
they been doing that
but that's at least
um
contrary to the definition of
anti-semitism
because the the traditional dictionary
definition of anti-semitism
is bias or hostility against jewish
people it doesn't mention anything about
telling facts about israel but now
there's been an effort for a number of
years this has gone on for a long time
i've documented in a in a long article
where israel partisans have now
fabricated a new definition of
anti-semitism in which many criticisms
and facts and statements about israel
are now under this new definition quote
anti-semitic
wow
so before we conclude
i wanted to share with you
if americans only knew because this is
our vision at the dean show is to bridge
the gap of misunderstanding and this is
one of the issues that's so important
that we can work on together as muslims
as christians i think it's so important
there's a lot of misconceptions and i
think that if these things are clear if
we can sit we can talk clear these
misconceptions and i just wanted to
share with the audience and i don't know
you might know this you might not but if
americans only knew because obviously as
a christian the one who's most beloved
to christians is jesus but did you know
allison that
muslims love jesus also it's an article
of faith to believe and love jesus
obviously as a mighty messenger not as a
god or literal son of god but we love
him we say peace be upon him
uh there's uh another person that we
love dearly and that's just like you
know imagine if someone says someone is
praising or talking good of uh someone
you love so deeply your mother your
father you know say i have high respect
for your parents you know but we're
saying we have high love and respect for
someone who is so close to christians
mary the mother of jesus there's a whole
chapter named after her in the in the
quran and she's she any picture out
there that you see over resembles like
what you're wearing right now the the
scarf yes
and then the last the the last point is
you know the main message of islam which
simply means to submit your will to one
and only god is the message of pure
monotheism worshiping the creator not
the creation and being morally upright
being kind and just with your neighbors
doesn't matter if it's christian jew
hindu buddhist doesn't matter so because
a lot of times
the media and a lot of times corrupt
politicians and others with you know a
hate agenda they'll push on propagate
that muslims are coming to get you
they're the boogeyman so that kind of
fosters a division a hate at least a
violence then we can't work together you
understand so
i just wanted to share that with you and
uh did you know some of these things
that i just mentioned
well i've learned them you know i did i
didn't really know them before
um i was not against muslims but i
wasn't very informed on them of course
but now in 20 years i've learned a lot
not just about israel-palestine but
muslims you know since
there are many christian you know
christian christianity of course as you
know but most americans forget also
began in palestine
so but you know the majority population
for
centuries has been muslim you know and
and uh so i've met many muslims here in
the united states and of course in
palestine where they come where they
come in to chop your head off or did you
feel
well when i go there i've traveled alone
by around by myself
um without with people coming up smiling
at me welcoming me often inviting me
into their homes giving me wonderful tea
so i've experienced that firsthand and
usually when i travel
you know since my custom i dress
modestly of course which is appropriate
but i don't i don't wear a head scarf
you know people can see i'm i'm it's not
hard to guess i'm a foreigner
but you know i'm not the only one who
does that because they're their
christian neighbors don't either and
they live side by side they work side by
side so i've i first hadn't experienced
that and i've had many people you know
now i've read about islam
and i've had people talk you know i know
that mary is very revered jesus is very
revered
um
i feel that it
i feel that the religions are very very
close
um very very similar yes that we have
much more in common much more common yes
so you know of course there are
extremists in every religion they're
extremists in christianity in islam and
judaism there are extremists
and the what's trying but you know again
the israel partisans the the worst ones
try to say that the the small portion of
muslims who are extremists but that
represents islam
it's completely unfair and untrue just
like saying some extremist christian who
does something horrible represents
christians no they don't it's going to
say these you know there's a great deal
of extremism
in in israel of of jewish extremism but
that does not you know
quite a bit really we don't read about
it but that does not represent judaism
or jewish
israelis or jewish americans
so
this is common sense but you know if
your barrage with
with often very slick propaganda people
don't always realize that
well we commend you doing some wonderful
work thank you so much if people wanted
to be it be a christian church or a
muslim organizat whoever and they wanted
to learn more how could they get a hold
of you to invite you are you still
accepting invitations that they wanted
to hear this one hour talk they really
wanted to get informed and get make an
educated decision
i'd be glad to do that you can go to our
website if
if americansnew.org
if
americansnew.org
there's a phone number there there are
emails they can email me
allison weir gmail.com
so i'd be very happy to do that and i
always have to say we we anybody that
wants to please feel free to make
donations it's completely tax deductible
and uh we use that information to
make videos to do articles i've written
a book i think i mentioned in fact i
hope people will buy my book
and give it to others so we we use that
information every way we can we're we're
working on a major project now that's
going to hit next next week
all of it requires money
so donations are very welcome too
god bless you god bless you for
educating the american public the world
and really what's going on
and being a voice for understanding
thank you so much
thank you god bless you
and thank you to our guest allison for
being with us and you can see this is a
person who has dedicated over 20 years
and has gotten informed and is willing
to inform you to come out to your
community
and it's about
if you are a true seeker god conscious
person
even if the truth goes against yourself
or what you've been taught
you're a person because you have god
consciousness because you want to do
what's morally right
you're going to go ahead and look beyond
those prejudices those biases and you're
going to look beyond the media hype and
you're going to dig for the truth a lot
of times you got to go through layers of
layers of layers of falsehood and
deception
to get to the truth
otherwise you end up staying in that pit
of darkness following your desires and
where you're going to end up from there
so there's a sad event anytime innocent
life is lost and this is not a muslim
jewish thing if you ask them that the
jews and muslims lived in peace
for for
over a thousand years
and why is it suddenly now suddenly now
that the muslims suddenly these guys
allegedly hate jews
clearly and and suddenly want to kill
them clearly it's zionism that's the
problem we were accepted in these muslim
and arabs we believe in one god and we
were accepted we have different ways of
serving god
but yet
as i
we were respected and even the muslim
religion requires of that
of the uh the muslim people to
to provide protection and hospitality
and they did uh carry that out that's
clear nobody could refute this fact um
although unfortunately zionism and the
zionist uh zionists try constantly to
vilify the muslim people and try to
recreate
a a scenario of as if we have some deep
embedded religious conflict and a hate
between jews and muslims and that is so
deplorable despicable and really it's
the words it's an akbar we've discussed
this so many times we brought israeli
rabbis
friends of mine also come on
who are people who are
advocating
for the rights of human beings who are
living in an open air prism
and that's
that side of the world can imagine put
yourself where you had limited
limited resources
your electricity is being cut off the
food that your your neighbor has you
can't have because he's on this side of
the fence
and the oppression with the checkpoints
etc etc so this is just something that
if it's happening in ukraine then the
whole world is up in arms but it's
happening here to muslims and christians
and most of the world is
you heard it silent
so let's be fair let's be consistent
and remember
you know if we go back in history you
see how jews fled persecution you have a
david warrenstein who was an academic
islam saved the jury
so if you really want to know what islam
stance is whereas
you know when islam was at the pinnacle
superpower muslims were
jews were fleeing persecution coming to
live in muslim lands and muslims are
simply those who
what you've heard it so many times here
on the deen show muslims are those who
submit their will to the one and only
creator of the heavens and earth just
like jesus moses abraham the last and
final master prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon them all muslims want
to live in peace with their neighbors
with
their countrymen but they put god first
and foremost the one creator of the
heavens and the earth and if you didn't
know you got to learn that muslims love
jesus there's a whole chapter named of
his blessed mother and you'll continue
to learn more if you tune in to the dean
show
and make sure you also support
the mega dawah center we're trying to
open sharing the purpose of life with
the people clear the many misconceptions
dedicated to that
and doing good in the community so
support the dean
center we're almost there
on what we need to finish and close on
the property
so make sure you do your part
and subscribe right now so you can get
all the latest shows sent to you hit the
notification bell and we'll see you next
time here god willing inshallah on the d
show and in the greetings of jesus who
would say shalom
[Music]
help us purchase this property to build
the dean center
donate right now may god almighty allah
reward all of you brothers and sisters
i cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you're not yet muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these muslims are
talking about and you'd like a free copy
of the quran go and visit the
deenshow.com we'll take care of the
postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions about islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you assalamu
alaikum and if you like this episode of
the dean show like this video
share this video far and wide